[Musique]
les joueurs alors il faut que je
rectifie que suite je veux pas en finir
avec la gastronomie moléculaire parce
que la gastro car c'est une discipline
scientifique que je pratique tous les
matins c'est pour ça que je vis donc je
vais certainement pas bons en finir avec
la gastronomie moléculaire qui est une
une discipline de physico-chimie en
revanche la cuisine moléculaire
ce qui est bien différent de la
gastronomie moléculaire il ya un mois de
cela donc cuisine d'une carte rose mais
ça veut pas dire la même chose
cuisine ça veut dire faire à manger
gastronomie dit ça veut dire pensez donc
la cuisine moléculaire que j'ai
introduite en 1981 celle là je veux la
tuer avec la cuisine note à note
bon alors il faut commencer maintenant
alors donc vous avez compris que il va
falloir mettre les choses au clair parce
que c'est pas c'est compliqué et si
j'avais le début je m'en serais bien
pour le merveilleux
moi je suis un enfant donc j'ai 6 ans je
m'émerveille encore de de cet autre show
dans laquelle on souffle et qui se
trouble
il trouve que ça sédimenter quand on
chauffe ça fait du carbonate
il ya un cycle transformation
moléculaire alors si j'allais le
powerpoint ça serait mieux mais sinon je
peux continuer quand même donc comment
sont quand même parle donc lever la
confusion il ya trois expressions a pas
confondre les voilà bah tu vois la
gastronomie moléculaire c'est une grosse
flèche envers c'est mon chemin c'est ma
vie c'est je lâche devrait être au
laboratoire pour faire ma gastronomie
moléculaire
elle se développe dans les laboratoires
du monde entier donc c'est tout bonheur
c'est ce que je veux la cuisine
moléculaire j'avais introduite en 1981
au même moment la cuisine moléculaire je
vous expliquerai vu brièvement ce que
c'est mais pour faire simple c'est une
cuisine rénovée techniquement au lieu
d'avoir des casseroles qui date du
moyen-âge et des fouets imbéciles qui
date d'il ya au moins cinquante ans on a
des objets techniques modernes et puis
on avance un peu plus vite parce que je
vous rappelle qu'il ya les 35 heures
s'il vous faut un quart d'heure pour
fouetter un blanc en neige alors que
nouveau vaut 15 secondes pour le faire
avec une pompe c'est pas la peine de
faire n'importe quoi en revanche
aujourd'hui pour s'émerveiller du futur
je vous propose la cuisine note à note
donc c'est pas de la gastronomie on a
via l'accord gastronomie en langue
français ça veut dire connaissance
raisonnée
tout ce qui se rapporte à l'être humain
qui se nourrit alors allons-y la
question c'est celle là moi demain je
serai mort enfin j'veux pas demain mais
un peu plus tard
et qu'est ce que vous vous allez manger
alors dans le fond je devrais pas moins
préoccupé parce que je serai bord dont
je m'en fous mais vous vous serez
peut-être là et mes enfants sont parmi
vous alors je vais pas insister donc il
ya des espèces qui disparaissent vous
les aurez pu sauf si un collègue qui
arrive à les faire revivre
c'est pas impossible il ya des choses
qu'on n'arrive pas à manger par exemple
au laboratoire de chimie l'agro paris
tech sont pas réussi à manger des
scorpions griller une crise de l'énergie
elle est quasi certaine
donc ça c'est intéressant et puis le
cheval plus passionnant c'est celui-là
c'est celui de la sao donc les chiffres
officiels il y aura donc entre 8 et
béton 11 milliards d'êtres humains sur
la terre
aujourd'hui on est 7 milliards il ya un
milliard qui a pas assez à manger ça
veut dire que comme on peut pas
augmenter tellement les terres agricoles
comment on peut pas augmenter tellement
la productivité il va y avoir trois
milliards de gens qui vont crever la
faim
et ça ça fait une guerre mondiale donc
il faut trouver les solutions dans la
présentation n'a pas dit que j'étais et
secrétaires delà de la section
alimentation humaine à l'académie
d'agriculture mais je peux vous assurer
que nous nous en préoccupons toutes les
secondes et ses milliards de gens ils
vont pas se nourrir d'odeurs de terrain
ils foncent nourrir d'ingrédients
alimentaires
alors voilà la question voilà tous ces
gens il fallait aller nourrir comment
est ce qu'on fait alors 10 milliards
c'est beaucoup d'abord il ya une
solution qui est envisagé actuellement
par l'ensemble des systèmes qui se
préoccupent de la question c'est le
gaspillage parce que alors les chiffres
sont contestables 45 d'autres 30
mais si on arrive à envoyer à supprimer
un tiers de gaspillage aujourd'hui même
au lieu de nourrir 6 milliards en or et
rennes 9 milliards donc là il ya une
vraie piste intéressante
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on gaspille on
gaspille pas parce que quand on achète
un produit à un agrément alimentaire on
va pas le jeter
donc le gaspillage c'est pas ça le
gaspillage tout simplement que quand
vous habitez à lyon à paris a pas de
pommiers dans lyon dont vous les fait
venir
répandre et dans le camion ça s'abîme et
puis il ya des insectes qui aime bien
les ingrédients nutritifs qui sont dans
la pomme
donc tout ça c'est ces tissus végétaux
et animaux
il faut les transporter et il arrive à
biner et donc il ya une loi la loi de
1905 qui dit qu'on ne peut pas vendre
des produits s'ils sont pas loin saint
loyaux et marchands et là ils les
passants parce que la pomme elle se
défend avec des pesticides naturels qui
sont sans doute beaucoup plus dangereux
que les vestiges des pesticides de
synthèse et sont plus dangereux parce
qu'ils sont pas sélectifs
quand un super là pour défendre
l'industrie alimentaire l'industrie
pharmaceutique mais quand vous faites un
pesticide aujourd'hui la loi impose de
protéger les êtres humains bon mais la
pomme elle s'en fiche de protéger les
êtres humains lsdh agresseurs et elle se
défend et donc il ya des pesticides 99
99 % des pesticides son fils naturel
donc ne nous trompons pas de combat
alors là c'est terrible voyez les
camions les 10 tonnes qui arrive dans
lyon pour apporter des aliments tous les
matins je sais pas combien il y en a
mais je crois qu'il ya 5000 sur paris
chaque jour ils transportent de la
flotte alors crise de l'énergie moi je
veux bien mais pourquoi transporter des
tomates
alors les enfants me répondra oui mais
les tomates c'est bon j'aime bien les
tomates ah oui les pommes c'est bon
j'aime bien les pommes mais oui mais
c'est du gâchis on transporte de l'eau
et en plus ça s'abîme alors du coup
c'est clair le moyen âge doit être un
peu dépassé
je vous rappelle que la tradition c'est
pas toujours bon l'esclavagé têt
traditionnel il n'était pas bon donc
changeons notre cuisine la cuisine
moléculaire n'est pas une réponse parce
que la définition 7,8 moléculaire que
j'avais introduite
ça veut dire cuisiner avec de nouveaux
outils l'azoté liquide des matches avant
c'était très bien à l'époque c'était il
ya 35 ans vous étiez pas né pour j'en
vois beaucoup qui sont étudiants dont
vous étiez pas né c'est un truc de vieux
donc oublions les truc de vieux passons
au futur alors quand même c'était pas
mal voilà des inventions j'ai fait j'ai
inventé un plat qui s'appelle le libye
qu'il a été cet art pierre gagnaire par
mon ami pierre gagnaire c'est
merveilleux c'est très bien
le presley donc tous les mois depuis 16
ans j'invente une préparation culinaire
nouvelles chaque mois je la donne
gratuitement sur internet sur le site de
pierre gagnaire donc en voilà deux ans
vole à 3 alors leur donne un nom de
chimistes parce que comme ça le public
manche de la chimie et il dit c'est bon
évidemment puisque c'est fait par qui a
gagné bon alors ça c'est une salade
rigolote par exemple voilà c'est une
feuille de laitue ça c'est une feuille
de tomates et ça c'est la feuille de
vinaigrette
bon on n'aura pas le prix nobel avec ça
alors vous oubliez s'il vous plaît
la cuisine moléculaire mais pas la
gastronomie moléculaire qui elle est la
base de tout de tout dans la vision
n'est d'accord alors la clean attaqué
nés en 94 parce qu'un jour je devais
écrire un article et j'ai eu l'idée de
cuisiner avec des composés alors
décomposer c'est des choses simples par
exemple le le sel c'est le sel le sucre
saccharose est un composé l'eau est un
composé l'huile c'est un mélange de
composer mais peu importe il y en a
plein des composés lors cépage et du
glucose de l'acide citrique et être
assez bon cuisine avec des composés eux
alors évidemment on se dit qu'il va nous
mettre de la chimie dans les aliments
non regardez quand même il ya 200 ans on
jouait du violon en cuisine avec des
carottes ou des navets ou des viandes et
des poissons
il ya cent ans on a commencé à analyser
les sons et on a commencé à analyser les
aliments il ya 50 ans il fallait une
pièce entière d'ordinateurs pour faire
un son de synthèse aujourd'hui ça coûte
22 euros dans un magasin de jouets vous
avez vu que sur la fin de l'histoire
j'ai pas raconter ce qu'elle laisse
passer en cuisine je vous laisse deviner
ce que je sais c'est que c'est un projet
artistique aujourd'hui même un chef
talentueux et à cracovie pour faire une
démonstration de cuisine note à note
et puis les ingrédients les à parce que
ils peuvent venir de la carotte
on va les fractionner comme on
fractionne du blé pour faire de l'amidon
et du gluten depuis 10 742 c'est pas
neuf
les techniques sont là ça c'est le pour
faire l'eau potable de la ville d'angers
ça ça coûte 2000 euros ça peut se mettre
dans une ferme et donc dans une ferme
l'agriculteur il peut faire de la valeur
ajoutée ou de zone des carottes qui vont
à bas prix
le nombre de combinaisons est infinie et
après il faut tout construire
on dira c'est compliqué de construire
parce que si on a un steak ont dès
maintenant c'est pas compliqué regardez
on va en faire un saint si j'ai le temps
parce que je n'ai que 11 minutes
alors on va commencer par prendre un peu
d'eau voilà l'eau c'est quand même la
base de la vie puisqu'on effets d'eau un
je vous rappelle que nous sommes fait de
2 70% d'eau à peu près voilà un peu
d'eau ensuite on est maître coup à
bastien on va y mettre des protéines des
protéines des protéines
alors je sais pas d'où elles viennent je
veux pas le savoir c'est des protéines
et je sais quelques réguler mans alors
ensuite on va fouetter
alors c'est plus efficace avec deux fois
ça s'appelle la technologie j'ai plus
rien c'est comme ça si je souhaite
simplement comme sage obtient un blanc
un blanc en neige mais c'est parce que
je veux tenir moi je veux tenir avec
quelqu'un m'aide à me tenir le ou alors
je le pose là dessus pour pas que ça
fasse de bruit voilà
mais enfin il faut faire c'est l'huile
quand même alors ah ben c'est très
gentil voilà vous avez vous versez
l'huile goutte-à-goutte je prenais la
bouteille était là bas ouais goutte à
goutte
il faut aller vite parce qu'elle est
parce qu on a douze minutes un bon angle
et le 10 minutes chez pas moi
goutte-à-goutte voilà donc le fouet
émulsionne l'huile dans l'eau
les protéines servant cela vous fait ça
parfaitement on l'applaudît il est très
bien un vrai bonheur voilà alors pour
l'instant on est en train de faire une
émulsion le mot vient des mules guéret
15 160 ambroise paré émulsion blanche
qui n'a aucun goût est là simplement
pour l'instant des nutriments un peu
d'huile et puis tout va bien on a notre
notre émulsion qui foisonnent un peu
voilà pas trop vite maintenant s'il vous
plaît voilà vous pouvez me verser du
sucre s'il vous plaît maintenant vous
avez le sucre dans le paquet là il n'est
pas cuisiner ça c'est le sel sel sel
mais une pincée quand même non grata
quai dans le paquet alors pendant que
moi je vous laisse je vous laisse le
faire pendant ce temps-là j'avance
d'envoyer qu' il n'y a rien de plus
simple un enfant y arrive
voilà le premier plat note à note qui
ait jamais été fait dans un restaurant
par mon ami pierre gagnaire c'est à hong
kong en 2009
et puis depuis il ya eu des plats et des
plages des plats alors au dp voyez il
traînait une framboise ça sert
exactement à rien ensuite la voilà un
plat qui était vraiment original pour
l'année de la chimie international on a
fait des plats celui-là ça plaît sur une
histoire sur une idée d'huîtres là
c'était un souffle
gros comme ça avec une sauce entièrement
un de synthèse ça c'est une vraie viande
le truc dégueulasse ça c'est une viande
artificielle ce qui est beaucoup plus
jolie
ensuite on a mis un dessert dont ils
traînaient des fruits ce n'était pas
utile
et puis on a continué et continue et
dans tous les pays du monde ça ça
développe dans tous les pays du monde je
suis très heureux je ne touche pas un
centime
donc je vous invite à penser la question
pourquoi est ce que je le fais je ne
gagne ni notoriété ni argent à votre
avis pourquoi là je vous ai offert la
question dont je continue à balayer mes
images copenhague montréal ont peut
construire les aliments à toutes les
échelles regarder un aliment s'est
construit à l'échelle macroscopique
microscopique nanoscopique moléculaire
on peut faire linverse et avec une
espèce de langage formel que j'ai
inventé en 2001 on a des formules pour
décrire des plats et ses plats n'importe
quel n'importe quel plat on le prend et
on a une formule et des formules on a on
peut décrire mais on peut aussi inventer
des tas de formule un nombre infini de
formuler avec ses formules nouvelles ont
fait des plats nouveau bon voilà par
exemple une orange artificiel j'ai
inventé une machine en même temps c'est
des pompes des micros réacteurs dans la
bonne chimie
on part d'une formule on a un plat voilà
ma connaissance le premier plat de
l'histoire la cuisine conçus par une
formule est fait par une machine
alors on a mis des ponts pour piloter on
a fait des cocktails celui là c'est un
prototype domestiques ont fait 500
milliards de combinaisons
l'imprimante 3d sur notre système
oubliez tout ça va très facilement et
finalement la question c'est est ce que
vous voulez changer si vous goûté ce
machin là il a goût parce qu'on a oublié
d'y mettre alors il n'a pas mis assez de
sucre et du sucre il a pas mis de
couleur on va lui mettre de la couleur
j'ai peut-être la couleur quelque part
ah tiens j'ai des polyphénols paris
c'est bon pour la santé des polyphonies
un bref vous avez compris qu'on peut
faire ce qu'on veut on va me dire ça
manque de consistance j'ai oublié on
aurait pu faire la chose suivante parce
que on le met là dedans on le voit dans
un four à micro ondes
ça va chauffer qu'est ce qui se passe
dans on sait exactement ce qui va se
passer
il va se passer que le les protéines
vont coagulé salle a gonflé et donc ça
fait un soufflé en 15 secondes
n'envoyez il n'y a pas de ya pas de
vraies difficultés alors qu'est-ce qu'on
veut changer de la réponse est non vous
êtes attachés à vos plats lyonnais
provence sauge pourquoi comme des
enfants non mais rappelez vous un moment
il ya eu un petit âge glaciaire faubourg
je surveille ma cuisine quand même parce
qu'en même temps il ya un petit âge
glaciaire il faisait froid en france et
le blé le blé ça doit être cuit avec ses
cuivres sait qu elle a pas encore assez
bon il ya eu un petit âge glaciaire et
parmentier au cusm parmentier est parti
en allemagne et il a vu qu'un pardon oui
je le ferai après ouais il a vu que en
allemagne ont crevé pas faim parce qu'on
mange des pommes de terre il est revenu
en france il a étudié les pommes de
terre
attention de bien enlever la peau qui
contient des glico avec loïc toxiques
1 c'est bien gentil d'avoir la peau qui
est un petit croustillant mais c'est
toxique quand même bon et puis il a fait
de la chimie et puis il a fait de la
cuisine et finalement il a fait manger
au roi
si le roi en mange le peuple en veut
alors le roi ça peut être
melba l'actrice melba pour la pêche
melba ça peut être lady gaga johnny
hallyday jean sérien fin c'est c'est le
roy on en parle à la télé quoi alors
voilà l'argument d'autorité c'est un
argument qui marche très bien
donc évidemment je fais pareil c'est
comme ça que j'ai réussi à introduire la
cuisine moléculaire
c'est comme ça que je réussis
aujourd'hui introduire la cuisine la
note mais là en plus j'ai de la chance
par rapport à pas menti parce qu'à
l'école voilà des enfants qui font 40
litres de blanc en neige avec un seul
blanc d'oeuf
ça va pas ça fera pas les mêmes adultes
que tu peux nous et donc ses enfants
sont prêts à passer à une alimentation
de demain pour les rois on sait où ils
vont ils vont là et donc on peut tout
faire bien voilà l'objectif il est il
est essentiel c'est quand même d'abord
de survivre mais survivre dans des
conditions pourries c'est pas la peine
en revanche je suis pas en train de
proposer une cuisine au rabais je suis
en train de proposer la cuisine des rois
pour tout le monde
il n'y a pas d'argent à gagner pour moi
en tout cas c'est une décision
personnelle
il ya des startups qui se créent des
étudiants je les encourage je les aide
ça sera leur alimentation il ya beaucoup
de travail à faire je n'ai pas dit que
la clean la note serait la solution
j'ai dit que quand viendra le moment du
choix ou
deux vont avoir des solutions notre
disposition pour faire notre choix est
ce que ça sera les ogm
est ce que ça sera la cuisine note à
note j'en sais rien je serai plus là ça
sera à vous de choisir
mais au moins vous aurez une possibilité
et j'espère que vous n'oublierez pas
donc l'essentiel qui est d'être heureux
ensemble sans se battre parce qu'il n'y
a pas de raison les hommes les femmes
les enfants tous ensemble dans le bloc
et le banquet pas seulement le banquet
de la tap
ou on est comme des animaux a bouffé non
le beau crier de la connaissance le
bouquet de la culture ça c'est essentiel
alors je sais que j'ai sans doute
chagriné certains on va dire ça comme ça
j'en ai vu lui au premier rang par
exemple un moment il fronça les sourcils
isère il ya les faits oui mais les gens
en général quand on leur présente ça je
sais maintenant parfaitement il
oui mais la nutrition oui ben la
toxicologie oui mais bon il ya les faits
oui mais donc pour ça je suis à votre
disposition
ah ben non ils ont enlevé lé email en
j'avais mis mon email pour que vous
puissiez m'engueuler parce que j'ai dit
des choses politiquement incorrect me
questionner alors je vous le donne c'est
hervé pointis atteindra point fr et
voilà les 12 minutes terminée vive la
connaissance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]